voiture qu'un directeur des essais en
vol de sud aviation jacques ablo
ingénieur en chef des essais en vol nord
aviation et bien votre présence ici
aujourd'hui est en quelque sorte
symbolique puisque nos deux entreprises
ont décidé de fusionner alors vous serez
kurka quels sont les rays cette
opération bien nous sommes fusionner
sous un titre qui comprend le moins
industriel je crois que c'est ça la
raison et android aurait dû dire même
industriel et commercial
nous sommes une société une depuis ce
matin destiné à vendre des avions et
ceux qui commandent la fusion c'est
précisément le marché de l'aviation qui
se développe avec une rapidité
considérable qui double environ tous les
sept ans et ceci représente une
multiplication du nombre des avions mais
aussi une augmentation de la dimension
de ses avions ait de l'importance de
tous nos programmes
la gamme de production de la nouvelle
société aérospatiale est désormais très
complet ici les engins ssds enfouis dans
le sol
les engins msb est lancée à partir sous
marins les fusées diamant qui ont déjà
mis sur orbite quatre satellites
artificiels français
les engins cibles
les missiles antichars et ses 111
ligne s'il milan
l'hélicoptère
les avions livrés
les célèbres caravelle l'airbus qui en
est encore au stade des maquettes
et enfin concorde ici en train de
survoler paris eh bien monsieur henri
ziegler positif ici le patron de sud
aviation et le gouvernement vous a
chargé d'assumer la présidence du
nouveau groupe
alors qu'est ce que l'on peut désormais
attendre de la société nationale
aérospatiale avec quarante deux mille
personnes et des perspectives
d'extension dans ce domaine et un
chiffre d'affaires au départ de l'ordre
de deux milliards et demi de francs
nous sommes de loin la première
entreprise aéronautique dans le marché
commun et quels sont alors vos grands
projets sur le plan des réalisations je
voudrais insister particulièrement sur
les deux programmes majeurs dont nous
avons la responsabilité celui de
concorde et celui d'airbus pour le
concorde
c'est un marché de 250 à lyon que nous
visons en coopération avec l'industrie
britannique et pour l'airbus est un
marché de 5 à 600 avions d'ici 1980 en
coopération avec les industries
allemandes britanniques hollandaise ce
sont là des programmes d'une ampleur
sans aucune mesure avec ceux qui ont été
conduits au cours des dernières années
en particulier le programme de caravelle
et il n'y a aucun doute que ce
regroupement des moyens ce regroupement
des forces nous mettra en association
avec nos collègues de l'industrie
européenne dans une position beaucoup
plus vigoureuse est beaucoup plus
dynamique pour faire face à l'énergie
que concurrence des grands industriels
américains